vous foutez pas de moi c'est du chiqué
je vous en prie j'aimerais voir ça
allez-y jeu attention ça va faire mal
une place mais n'a été rude on vous en
voudra pas s'il va rassurer
vous oubliez que j'ai vu comment vous
faites et je sais toujours pas comment
vous faites raymond s'élança est assez
éloquent si je vous en prie pas démontré
le haut je n'ai jamais reculé devant un
défi honnête sens bien c'est de la
physique la piste bon alors si je
soulève le jeu devient le roi date garde
oui bien sûr bon je commencerai pas à
rétablir le droit de cuissage
nous avons déjà bien tu tiens vraiment
là est tout à fait logique dans les bras
war machine mon pote
allez on y va
à aller capter
des années